vous le savez le pentagone surveille à
chaque mouvement des troupes russes
depuis le début du conflit et la défense
américaine a vu les dégâts subis par ce
croiseur le moskva matthieu mabin
bonjour vous êtes notre correspondant à
washington
quelles sont les informations
américaines sur ce navire le moskva
désormais couler
oui vous savez tout au long du conflit
avant même le déclenchement de
l'offensive russe lucre sur l'ukraine le
24 février dernier le renseignement
généreusement livrée par le pentagone
sous la forme de communiqués de presse a
eu un impact réel sur le déroulement
même des opérations sur le terrain est
effectivement alors que moscou tentait
de minimiser les avaries sur le moskva
son navire amiral en mer noire le
pentagone livré une toute autre version
alors que moscou parlait d'un incendie
accidentel à bord et du remorquage du
bâtiment afin de réparation le ministère
de la défense américain affirmait lui
depuis ce matin que les incendies à bord
étaient toujours en cours ce qui
annonçait d'une part qu'aucun remorquage
n'était possible mais surtout que le
navire était bel et bien menacé de
sombrer à leur enseignement et
l'imagerie dont disposent leurs forces
américaines au dessus de la mer noire
offre effectivement au pentagone une vue
imprenable sur le déroulement des
opérations y compris en mer et sur ce
site ce qui se passe réellement sur le
terrain une vision probablement
meilleure que celle des ukrainiens
d'abord mais également que celle des
russes tout simplement or on peut
désormais croire le pentagone les forces
iraniennes sont bel et bien parvenu à
frapper le navire russe par une action
habile et combiné de survol de drones et
de tirs de missiles depuis la terre à
des missiles qui sont effectivement à
l'origine d'un incendie à bord qui se
serait propagé à la soute à munitions
laquelle soutes à munitions se trouvait
sous la ligne de flottaison du bâtiment
on comprend alors que le bâtiment hors
de combat ne pouvait plus que compter
ses heures en surface le naufrage est il
nécessaire de le préciser constitue en
soi un coup magistral porté par
l'ukraine aux envahisseurs russe il
reste une inconnue cependant sur les 500
membres d'équipage
combien ont sombré avec leurs bâtiments